وبعد خطاب الرئيس نحن
ما زلنا نهاجم نحن
دائما يهاجمها السكان بذلك
نحن خائفون
تم طردنا ، لا نعرف
لماذا هذا هو عملنا
وقع الأطفال علينا
من أجلنا
أختي
كان علينا العد التنازلي بعد هذا
الصباح نقول من المنزل حسنًا ، إنه ليس كذلك
إلى أين نذهب ليس لدينا أي أقارب هنا
نحن جميعاً أفارقة
[موسيقى]
تمامًا مثل هذا حتى لو لم يكن علينا ذلك
اعتقالات
نصدر بيانا صحفيا جاء كل شيء
للذهاب إلى مركز الشرطة
التحقق من الهوية أولئك الذين هم
تعال عن طريق الطريق أولئك الذين ليسوا كذلك
جاء عن طريق البر
[موسيقى]
أكثر في المنزل نعيش في الشارع
معاش في الشوارع أيضا نحن
يجب على المهاجم على السكان
اذهب الى السفارة
معرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا المساعدة كثيرًا
لم تعد تعود إلينا